hi this is pressure Locker in this video
I'll teach you a math trick so that you
can multiply any number by eleven in
your head you probably already know how
to multiply a single digit number by
eleven you simply write the number two
times and that's how you multiply the
number by eleven but what if you want to
multiply a two-digit number by eleven
the trick involves three steps first you
copy the first digit of the number the
second step is to add the two digits of
the number then you copy the last digit
of the number and that's your answer
seventeen times eleven is 187 to do
twenty-six times eleven we first copy
over the first digit then we take 2 plus
6 is 8 and then we copy the last digit
of the number to do 52 by eleven we copy
the first digit of the number five then
we take five plus two as our next number
and then we copy the last digit to get
572 478 times eleven we copy the first
digit of the number to get seven then we
need to do seven plus eight this number
is 15 so we need to write it as one and
five we then copy over the last digit of
the number eight now we need to take
care of the 1 by carrying it over to the
7 so we're going to delete the 7 and
make it eight and that's our answer
858 let's do another example of carrying
over 49 times eleven we copy over the
four then we do four plus nine is 13 and
finally we copy over the nine to account
for the carry over one we turn the 4
into a five let's say we want to
multiply a three digit number or larger
number it's exactly the same steps we're
going to copy over the first and last
digit numbers and we're going to add the
numbers that are in between so for 123
times 11 we
copy over the 1 then we take one plus
two as our next digit to get three then
we take 2 plus 3 which is 5 and finally
we copy over the last digit we could do
this for any size number we want we
first copy over the first stage of the
number then we add up the digits that
are in between so we take 1 plus 5 to
get 6 5 plus 3 to get 8 3 plus 4 is 7 4
plus 2 is 6 and finally we copy over the
last digit
here's a short proof of why the trick
works when we multiply a number by 11
that's the same thing as multiplying it
by 10 plus 1 we can write this in
another way as ABCD 0 plus ABCD now it's
very easy to see if we add up column by
column that the result is a a plus b b
plus c c plus d and d which is exactly
the trick we've been using i hope you
like this video please subscribe to my
channel i make videos on math and game
theory you can support mind your
decisions on patreon where you'll get
exclusive rewards you can also catch us
on our blog bind your decisions on
twitter at pressure Walker or get our
books at Amazon